[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
make way for bob costas the hall of fame
broadcaster
hbo's back on the record with bob costas
that will make its debut this friday
night at 11
p.m eastern and pacific it can also be
streamed on hbo max
each episode features extended
conversations with some of the biggest
names in sports
from present-day superstars to legends
of the past
bob joins us now so who's the first
guest on friday night bob
well it's an obvious get you might say
but charles barkley
is the lead off and the difference
between this we hope and how you see him
on
tnt where it's so terrific with ernie
and the gang
is that this will be a more extended
conversation i'm sure a lot of it will
be very funny
uh almost inevitably it'll be
provocative so we'll have that and then
we have ali raisman which turns out to
be even more timely than we thought when
we booked it
we'll have a closing essay and
commentary bomani jones is a regular on
the show he'll be
part of a three-person panel every show
the other two people this time are renee
montgomery the former wnba star who's
now a part owner of the atlanta dream
in the league and david cohen the yankee
pitcher to talk about
a former yankee pitcher now broadcaster
to talk about a lot of what's going on
in baseball what are you looking for in
this show
you know the name pretty much says it
back on the record we're not reinventing
anything i did the on the record show
from 01 through
08 on hbo and then when the baseball
network came into existence
they wanted me to be part of that and
baseball is my favorite sport so i
wanted to do it
and hbo at that time said hey we want
you to stay but you got to choose
so i chose the baseball and reluctantly
left hbo behind
otherwise i would have just stayed
indefinitely now things have changed a
little bit
they invited me back i'm only doing four
of them a year
at this point dan you know you're
working five days a week that's not my
that's not my
ideal situation anymore um so it's
supposed to be quarterly we got pushed
back a couple of times by covid
so we'll do one a month for the next
four months just to get the four
in for 2021 then next year we'll go on a
quarterly cycle
um and i think the the idea is um
hbo already has real sports it's the 60
minutes of sports
it's fantastic on its own terms we're
not trying to replicate that
not trying to replicate what we see on a
daily or
weekly basis on cable tv sports coverage
i just hope that on its own terms it's
good i hope that
uh there's some depth to it some
entertainment to it i hope it brings to
bear some of the things i've done
reasonably well over the course of my
career
who is your favorite guest from on the
record
the one they talk about the most is
vince mcmahon
um it was good television uh hbo no
commercials and it was live
it turned out to be 27 28 minutes of
unremitting tension
and then after he went storming off the
set all we had was like a 20-second
bumper to get me to the next
uh setup on the set so i walk over and
sit down
and the next guest is bob knight
i said coach this is the one or only
time in your life when your presence
will lower the temperature in the room
did you think vince mcmahon was going to
hit you no
no i knew he was obviously you know
getting very very angry that was
authentic
he was very very angry and i think he
was trying to intimidate me through body
language and jabbing a finger at me
but you know maybe i'm just dumb but i
never thought he was going to smack me
okay so now he goes storming off and you
know how heavy
uh the doors are to his studio he
slammed that thing as if it was a screen
door on your back porch in mayberry
i mean you could hear the thing
reverberate and so now
the show is over and the stage manager
and some of the cameramen come up hey
bob
if you jumped here we had your back wait
a minute
you're over here behind a mile a table
i'm six inches from this madman
can you watch the olympics as a fan now
yeah
yeah you know i watch it casually just
like i did
the 2018 winter games from pyeongchang
i'm interested not only in
some of the competition but in how my
former colleagues and long-time friends
are doing i've texted a few of them uh
before and during the games
but i'm not obsessed with it i'm not
sitting there monitoring it if
if i plop down on the couch and
something's going on then i check it out
and of all the great things you did with
the olympics and i'm sure
pinkeye conjunctivitis still comes up
certainly
in the time of the olympics how often
does it come up
it comes up pretty frequently and i know
it's part of my
obituary uh and in the darker recesses
of
the internet there are bizarre theories
as to how i contracted
it none of which are remotely true um
you know but you have to have a sense of
humor about it at the time
i tried to just you know acknowledge it
you had to if you just felt lousy you
could you go to work we've all done that
if i had a broken leg it would have been
in a cast under the desk wouldn't have
to refer to it
but it was literally written right there
on my face so i i just tried to
have a line or two to acknowledge it and
then move on as best i could
but the amazing thing is that some
people
think that i am subject to illness and
specifically pink eye
only during the olympics so we go from
2014
to 2016 in rio and it's like
bob how are your eyes what is it for
only during that specific quadrennial
period
that i'm going to get pink wait do you
have it this week you didn't get it that
list
this week no okay okay no i think i
pulled a hamstring getting out of bed
but apart from that
when you know the results and it's tape
delayed but
do you have to pre can you present it or
is the feeling to present it in a way
that hey i'm gonna
act as if i don't know what happened no
i i think what we always tried to do was
acknowledge
on the first night of competition not
the opening ceremony but the first night
of full competition
uh if it was the circumstance where
all of it had to be presented on tape or
a substantial amount
you acknowledge that and then you try
and use
the right tense instead of
is going for his or her second gold
medal
was going for his or her second gold
medal i'm sure there were unintentional
slip
ups occasionally uh but
you try to let them know up front this
is what it is
you don't reiterate it every night
because some people want to experience
it
as as they're watching it if not as it
happens we hear that all the time if you
don't want to know the result turn away
but now as the world has changed a whole
lot since my first olympics in
1988 we know that millions and millions
of people
are aware of what's happened and uh
but millions more still just want to see
it
with the full presentation with the back
stories and the features
and everything else the most extreme was
sydney
in 2000 where you're literally a world
away
and some of the events that i was
leading into
the next day not only did i know the
result
i had attended them the night before and
i'm reading about them
in the sydney newspapers as i'm in the
car on the way to the studio
so i felt then as if i was on the
history channel
you didn't have a cutaway of you in the
crowd where you then commented on you
being in the crowd while you were
hosting the olympics did you you know i
was not
bright enough to demand that that would
have been very amusing but it didn't
happen
how often have you doubted yourself when
you're broadcasting
uh you know i don't want to get too
deeply into this but when you're doing
play-by-play
um in my case baseball now
and you get into your 60s you have to
realize that
unless you really watch it you're not
exactly as sharp as it used to be
you know during covid before there were
any games
both the nba network and uh the baseball
network
were showing classic games uh and i
would stumble
across some of them in fact i think it
was on your show dan when al michaels
and i were on at the same time
and al said i'm on three networks at
once
football baseball and and nba games and
on occasion i was on at least two at
once and then youtube
uh tosses stuff out there stuff you
don't even remember doing or haven't
thought about
in a long time and i contrast the level
of
sharpness from the 80s and 90s you know
i think i'm still pretty sharp but
is there a fall off that at least i can
recognize from maybe 100 percent
to 92 or 93 on occasion
yeah and so maybe like a pitcher whose
stuff has changed but can still be
effective
you change your approach a little bit
so i i have to be careful and the other
thing
that that's happened is you know your
eyesight isn't quite as good
as as you get older um and so in
baseball
unlike basketball or something that
wouldn't affect me much in baseball
you're calling the game you got a
monitor in the booth but
if there's a long fly ball to the
outfield and you're recessed from
the backstop by i don't know how many
feet but you're probably at that point
600 700 feet away with the naked eye
you can't 100 trust yourself on the
flight of the ball so you got to go
you got to go off the monitor so i tend
to i tend to slow things down
a little bit rather than rather than
just
kind of jumping on it right away i try
to be a little bit more cautious
what a boring answer but you asked uh
but then
you have the luxury of a shohei otani
home run where you don't have to go
i don't know if that's going to get out
of here yeah that's right
i've never can you remember and you've
been at the ballpark all your life but
the
sound is different bob with shohei
ohtani
yeah there have been through the years a
handful
of hitters for whom that applies i
remember
the late great buck o'neil talking about
that and saying
when he closed his eyes he knew it was
babe ruth
or josh gibson the other one he cited
from
the negro leagues and then later on
mickey mantle and then after that
bo jackson um i think shohei is on that
short list
where literally if you turned your back
during batting practice
the sound coming off their bats was
different yeah i would go
you could go and just listen to batting
practice with ohtani and be entertained
you don't even have to watch
because i i love the it's in your mind
like oh my god where's that gone it's
like radio if you listen
that you just hear the crack of the bat
and it's just
it's seton do you have shohei ohtani's
home run from last night
see if we can okay here you go
[Applause]
it's it sounds like it's out of a
cartoon doesn't it
it sure does and you know people talk
about the launch angle
approach and some are critical of it
because it's part of what's
created these three perfect outcomes
strikeout
walk home run deprives baseball of
action but when you have someone who's
perfected it
if ted williams saw shohei otani he
would approve
of shohei's approach it is a perfect
natural uppercut swing but he also
excels at putting the ball in play
i mean there's a guy who'll pitch six
innings for you maybe six shutout
innings
i haven't checked recently but at one
point he led the league in triples
he steals bases he does everything
is he better than babe ruth
so difficult to compare ruth when he was
primarily pitching
was one are the great pictures of his
time and would have made the hall of
fame
as a pitcher and then when he became
primarily a hitter
almost exclusively he dominated the
league in a way that no one else
has in baseball it's comparable to wilt
chamberlain
averaging 50 in basketball or wayne
gretzky's
uh gap over everyone else and goals
assists and
total points before the rest of baseball
sort of caught up ruth was ruth was
hitting more home runs than entire teams
so but he never he never blended hitting
and pitching
at this level of effectiveness the way
ohtani did
so you can make a case for ohtani
looking at it from that perspective
another case for ruth from the other
perspective and then you just have to
say wait a minute you know comparing
eras and the
circumstances under which they competed
makes it an interesting parlor game but
you can never arrive at a definitive
answer
you remember your first game in person
yeah
yeah um well actually i got to give two
answers to this
my dad i don't know if he was prescient
or it was just
luck in 1957 i'm five years old
he took me to a game at ebbets field so
i can say i went to a game at ebbets
fields i don't remember anything except
how green the grass was and you've heard
people tell that story all the time it's
like
dorothy arriving in oz and it goes from
black and white uh to color because all
anybody had then was a
black and white television set with a
tiny screen i don't remember any
particulars of the game
he also took me to one at the polo
grounds and as i'm sitting on his
shoulders toward the back of the
grandstand
he said to me bobby look at that player
right there
no no not that one the one in the middle
that's
willie mays as if he was far sighted
enough to know
that that would be something i'd want to
remember for the rest of my life as if
he was saying son
that's the washington monument that's
the eiffel tower
that's willie mays but i don't remember
any particulars of the game
the game i remember i was seven and my
dad took me to a late season game
between the orioles and the yankees
at the old yankee stadium and i was
heartbroken that mantle didn't play
that day and the orioles won the game
seven to two
and back then you could leave they'd let
the fans leave
by walking around the warning track and
then they'd open up the bullpen gates
and you poured out into the street where
the elevated subway was
so we walk around and it's awe-inspiring
enough the old yankee stadium the
wedding cake facade
the three decks of the whole thing but
then
the monuments and there were only three
of them at that time the monuments were
on the field
because center field was 461 feet from
home plate
so the three monuments to ruth gehrig
and their manager miller huggins
are right there with the flagpole behind
it
and we get to the monuments and what
would any seven-year-old kid think
i thought they were buried there on the
warning track
i i honestly thought that this this was
the sacred yankee burial ground
and joe dimaggio would be interred there
and eventually this is the part that
really got to me
mickey mantle was going to be buried
there
and i started to cry
my father's trying to assure me yeah
these three guys are dead
but they're buried someplace else given
the craziness of this
you know sports collecting business uh
how valuable are your baseball cards
your mickey mantle card
you know the one that i save is from
1958
the first one i remember getting out of
a top pack
of tops bubble gum cards i imagine that
one's worth
since it's in pretty good condition
somewhere in the single digits in the
thousands maybe four or five thousand
but you know a mint condition 1952
mantle
uh there was a big story recently in
sports illustrated about this
uh those are going for the into the
millions of dollars
bob has got his uh new show it's old
show just it's a newer version of his
older show it's called back on the
record with bob costas
that'll be uh coming up this friday
night at 11 eastern 11 pacific charles
barkley will sit down with him back on
the record with bob costas
great to have you back on the show bob
thanks for joining us as always and good
luck with the program
thanks a lot dan see ya all right we'll
take a break we'll come back
after this